I just wanted to share with you a
romantic technique that that's really
enhanced my relationship lately my
girlfriend I've been in role-playing
role play and it's it's it's fun the
other night she was uh Secretary of
Housing and Urban Development and I was
I was deputy secretary of housing or the
development was that there was that
status thing she was my boss and I I
didn't feel she pushed her agenda enough
my favorite one is a professor and
senior who needs to pass my class to
graduate so I'm a professor at a
prestigious New England University and
my girlfriend is a senior in my intro to
Western Civ and I know why is she a
senior in the intro she gave me some BS
about transferring in mid semester for
me I don't remember I didn't buy it
either so but she seemed like a good kid
she came
so she comes to my office hours Monday
Wednesday 3:00 to 5:00 and by
appointment and she's wearing a very
revealing tank top little skirt high
heels I know something's up I'm wearing
an argyle sweater over an oxford
button-down tan khakis chocolate brown
loafers with a belt to match I look the
balls I got a touch a little bit of
Cologne on not so much it's wafting off
into the deans reception area but enough
for if you get close you're like he came
to play today
so she says uh excuse me um professor
Lewis I can't use my real last name at
this College because they don't hire
Jews something I'll address once I have
tenure but for now it's go along to get
along
so she says excuse me professor Lewis I
I think I might be in danger of failing
your intro to Western Civ and I I just
want you to know I'm willing to do
anything to pass and I said anything and
she's saying and so I looked at my rank
book and sure enough she's gonna have to
pull out all the stops I I only give a
midterm in a final she got a 57 on the
midterm what was the median grade good
question that nobody asked 83 83 the
kids did pretty good I miss one so what
am I saying I'm saying even with the
curve I don't have a lot of wiggle room
but but a lot of times if you if you
show up to class and you and you
participate about pass you I'll bump
your grade up I'm I'm strict but I'm
fair that's that's sort of my rep on
campus oh you got you got Louis yeah
he's strict but he's fair and I heard
he's a Jew he's either a jerries had the
flu for Rosh Hashanah in a row
so I said uh obviously her attendance is
abysmal
the only time she raised her hand is
tasks if it's gonna be on the test you
know one of those and uh so I said how
do you feel about a little extra credit
she said oh yeah you're gonna give me
some extra credit I would love I said
I'll give you more extra credit than you
can handle
she said I believe I can take every inch
of your extra credit and I said that's
not how we measure extra credit
I don't know what they did at UMass but
here here we go by pages I'd like you to
write a 12 page paper on the Industrial
Revolution or an equally broad topic of
your choice strict but fair and if you
get a 70 or better on the final I'll
pass you and she said I don't think you
understand I'll do said no no it's you
that doesn't understand a 12-page paper
falls within the realm of anything it's
it's a subset of anything I don't have
to draw a Venn diagram for you that's
more of a math department thing I don't
want to step on any toes now by this
time my girlfriend is uh she's
frustrated and a little angry and she
said uh Gary Gary are we gonna have sex
tonight or should I just put on my
pajamas
she broke character I was furious it's
finals week I'm not wearing an argyle
sweater I'm sweating my balls off and
she wants to know are we gonna have sex
have sex are you gonna buckle down and
stop wasting your parents money and I
realized that at that point I didn't
want to have sex with her I wanted her
to be a better student she went to bed I
didn't care I had papers to grade thank
you so much
[Applause]